CHARLES NESSON: You can't tell the
story of the American jury
without telling the story of America.
It starts with the
Declaration of Independence
in which we, as a legal matter, define
ourselves as an independent people
and assert our sovereignty as a people.
That is the Declaration of Independence.
We don't get to the jury until we
get to the Constitution of the state.
In the Constitution of the state, the
jury is the method that we the people
adopted as our strategy
for controlling the state.
The most fundamental relationship
between citizen and state
is defined by the jury.
The jury took two forms.
The core idea is one of justice.
And the core idea of
justice is fair trial.
And the fair trial has
three parts-- a fair charge,
a fair opportunity to
defend, and a fair verdict.
The jury is the linchpin of fair trial.
First, with respect to the
charge, the grand jury.
The idea was we the
people should control
what charge can be brought
against a person that
can put him in such jeopardy
before a jury of his peers
that they could take his freedom away.
That's the grand jury.
And then, the opportunity
to defend, that
becomes cross-examination,
the high points of the trial,
the actual testing of the witnesses
who have made the charge, and then
the verdict.
And that's the petit jury.
The idea of 12 coming
to a unanimous verdict.
And that's the idea of the jury.
And the thought is that if the state
couldn't take a man's freedom away
unless he had a fair trial, the
jury was the bulwark of freedom.
That's the story of the jury.